good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday that
feels like a monday because it's our
first episode like together in real time
hope everyone enjoyed yesterday's
podcast only episode
you have a very special episode today
because it's a jackson claude
down
no
jackson claude
beneath the mason dixon
no
yes it's southern but it's not like my
mouth
it's not my mom no that's but that's
something else just people say like
welcome to the south when you're apart
and i guess technically geographically
it is south but like it's not this is
the south bless your heart southern tea
yeah exactly it's not southern charm
right i mean
i wish it was but you know what we do
have
flamingos yes so if you're watching on
youtube you're welcome um our gorgeous
faces are back together i'm in florida
staying at jackie's house for the week
to record a couple episodes and just do
some tunes you know we're doing a spritz
meet and greet in florida tomorrow we
are we're so excited tomorrow six
o'clock all the information's on the
sprint's instagram it's gonna be lit
your girls are together we haven't done
anger yet i've done you've done i've
been together since like the days of
caroline's yeah and we've only ever done
like three live shows in our entire
podcast square which is so crazy i
actually don't even think we did
actually we didn't mean yeah
but we've never done a spritz meeting
great so the florida toasters are
extremely privileged i wonder if you're
going to like my meet-and-greet style oh
what is your style uh i like i mean as
much as like i want to get through it
like i really get involved with everyone
of course this has such a fabulous story
and everyone is just so fabulous you
know everyone like waited online like
you can't just rush them out but like
everyone's wearing something interesting
like coming with an interesting gift
bringing their babies in
an interesting story a funny way of
having found the toast a friend on
facetime like there's just so much to do
there's so much things
being the president of the united states
is such hard work yeah don't worry i
won't kiss your babies but claudia might
oh no i will ask remission and if
granted i would definitely kiss your
babies is that weird like i don't think
it is
uh i think they're i think it's okay
because i know you and and i know that
you're like a loving person and
clean yeah no extremely like i took a
bath last night a long one oh my god i
went into her room to check on her twice
and she was in the bath so tell me about
your stay here so i arrived to jackie's
yesterday as you guys know i always
stayed olivia's because jeffy never
lived here but this time i'm staying
here we're podcasting so it's definitely
an easier commute you definitely have
that here i'll compare you know not to
pit women against women but that is
precisely what i'm gonna do now that we
know that you don't support women no i
definitely don't um
here's where you are winning
the tub
is so gorgeous so deep fit for you know
a real woman
and olivia's time is nice but it's not
as big got it um and this is not really
you but it's more so like i prepared to
come here i had so much like amazon
packages sent here i have a whole new
set of makeup and like that's i just
feel more at home because my [ __ ] is
here yeah um so it really doesn't have a
lot to do with you no offense um in
terms of entertainment value i have
rolled and i have k so it's really equal
right i don't have a tv in my room yet
which is fine actually because i read
and when i was at olivia's house i
didn't even turn on the tv but last
night it wasn't a part of your ride or
in your list of demands otherwise i
would i have one for that room and i
would have set it up but like last night
i was like thinking oh i wish i had a
television you know okay we can set it
up today um
the other thing that there's bryce here
does that change things it doesn't
change things because like theo is my
heart but you have like dog tings here
you know yeah like i didn't even think
about bringing like a bowl for theo's
food to olivia's house i was then i was
just like using her tupperware and i'm
like that's so disrespectful so you just
have like treats like you like i didn't
have to bring all the accoutrements
doggie bags like you're a dog friendly
home yeah friendly living and theo gets
to pal around with bryce which is always
a pleasure and zach even offered to pick
up theo's duty today which was so nice
so crazy at first i said no but then i
think he was like can you please pick up
the [ __ ] so he did it because like i was
just taking my time that's why you said
by that tree
yeah yeah yeah i didn't understand what
you were saying okay so it's extremely
dog friendly um now the only downside
which is really really important and
that um olivia is still in the lead is
the air conditioning and i'm not being
ungrateful because i know like i'm in a
zone with harry like harry can't sleep
in 59 degrees like i totally understand
and last night zach was like let me get
you a fan and i was like no no how bad
could it be
were you really that hot yes but also
like you have gorgeous sheets that are
like a little too warm you know
so i was just like really hot in my
sleep which is just like one thing i i
personally cannot i mean we'll try and
make it cooler tonight and i guess harry
will just have to freeze no see the
thing is like i'm not gonna put my you
know [ __ ] on harry like i have a list of
things i need to get dry shampoo
hairspray and i'm just gonna pick up a
fan like a fan is what i need i will
wake up with crazy hair and a nose drier
than the sahara like that's what i do
for old
for a roll and i was convinced i
wouldn't hear world crying in the night
and of course i didn't and didn't bother
me at all literally no oh great it's
like a lullaby oh is somebody playing
the most beautiful thing i've ever heard
great i'll go back to sleep
um before claudia went to sleep i was
like i wonder you know if you hear him
which you will we all hear him like
you know don't worry don't move a muscle
she was like i'm not going she really
thought she wouldn't hear him because
you know you don't have to get up for it
like maybe you can just ignore it but no
he made sure everyone could hear him he
was extremely loud but i really cannot
stress how little it bothered me and how
not once did i think about getting up
like i know you guys got it you know
babies cry like there's something wrong
it's just crying yeah they're saying
like we know what to do yeah no like
i have so much faith in you and zach's
parents i didn't move a muscle i'm so
glad to hear that great snacks great
ambiance great bathroom products i'm
really really enjoying myself
thanks and you know this we're just
getting started right just moved in it's
only gonna get better no totally i feel
like this is like the most bare bones my
room will ever be and it's still
extremely bony and also if the
temperature continues to be an issue
like eventually for your next day we can
put in a ceiling fan
i mean
if you want me to be
happy like a ceiling fan is literally
all i need ceiling fans are the most
underrated
decor
is it decor yeah kind of
it is like whenever i'm in the hotel and
there's a ceiling fan i'm like five
stars five keys
five keys you know what i was thinking
just switching gears for a second at
hotel nantucket because um margo was
saying that the hotel should say that
was not five keys
have you ever stayed at a hotel that's
even like
four keys where it's like every need was
met and like you're like just like how
shelley was saying like you know within
five minutes your bags are up every time
you call it's there immediately like
honestly no
yeah
where i don't know i just like i stayed
at good hotels the service is really
good i just feel like i've never
experienced service that that's like
exactly as it should be maybe you're the
particular judge right to one no like
when you get your bags when you get them
they'll throw them up when you get them
you order room service sure one day
everything comes in plastic these days
and services is on the decline right
that what you just said about plastic
room service i think let's talk about
that yes room service is kind of
becoming a thing of the past it's like
yeah we haven't all bought a pond down
the block get yourself yeah it's more
like take out yeah it's a lost art i
completely agree i think during well
there's always been like a varying level
of hotels where like if you order room
service at a like more nice expensive
hotel like you'll get a whole tray
candle salt pepper the whole thing and
then if you're staying at like a more
budget-friendly hotel sometimes they'll
deliver room service in plastic bags and
when i'm on tour the hotels that i stay
at are usually um more plastic bag vibes
it doesn't really bother me because i'm
on tour but it is food but a lot of
places don't even do room service
anymore like went the way of covid and
they're not bringing it back and they're
they're saying it's because the
covenant's like code's done no but also
room service they also say like the
hours so it's like oh sorry we only go
from 401 to 47 am
but a lot of the nice hotels moved to
plastic takeout tupperware vibes during
cobin and have not moved back no because
it's like cheaper yeah of course
everyone can blame everything on
movement oh we can't get furniture at
covent right no it's true i can't even
get you your wedding pictures supply
chain jackie but you actually can't get
furniture going
no you can't but like
code's over where's my car no but like i
think the supply chain
we actually have a lot of people who
listen to the show who are supply chain
like
peeps like they work yeah i've seen some
i've seen it's like it's incredibly
delayed like we're feeling the effects
that's what they said it's it's going on
far too long it's becoming one of these
things where it's like we're just
accepting and they're just blaming coven
and like let's dive into the supply
chain yeah there is the missing link on
a personal level like i love one of the
great things about living in like a
post-pandemic era is like having a
a go-to excuse for tings you know like
if i don't want to do something or if i
don't want to shut up i can expose you
know and then i never get covered
because like i just got exposed and it
knows up in the air so on a personal
level i love that element of kobe as
like a consumer um i'm not crazy about
that you know how like people are just
like doing stuff and being like coping
no no it's becoming like like go-to and
things aren't working properly and like
if you're here and there okay you want
to take your time with the wedding
pictures sure whatever but you can't get
anything but by the way there's no room
service the wedding pictures i actually
understand is an av girly there's a chip
shortage i mean they're familiar with i
am familiar with youtube charity
saturday there's a car shortage that's
why there's like best buy shortages
right because i went to best buy and i
really kind of learned a lot about the
chip shortage i hadn't heard about the
chip shortage oh it's been going on for
years i had no idea and so like all
these companies are only selling their
most expensive [ __ ] with chips because
they only have so many chips aren't
gonna put in the 100 camera let me guess
cobin yeah
well actually your exposed excuse
doesn't even work anymore because you
saw that now like all the guidelines
have been dropped really [ __ ] and if
you've been exposed that you don't have
to but i'm like so cautious you know
and that's just a little bit about me
like i'm an extremely kind of thoughtful
person yeah i have nieces and nephews
like i can't be there
so
yeah i'm still gonna do that
yeah i think that's just me like i'm not
judging anyone who doesn't you know care
about other people as much as me you're
saving lives thank you
you're welcome
yeah welcome so it's tuesday we've got a
fabulous show because we're two fabulous
girls wait i have two things written
down that i wanted to discuss let me
just make sure i hit both of them i had
a few things that i wanted to discuss as
well um
yesterday we recorded for sunday so i
think like the date wasn't no sunday we
recorded for yesterday yeah the date
wasn't seared into my mind and i forgot
to let everyone know that yesterday was
bruno's birthday bruno is now my
two-year-old king
and
i'm just feeling so
so proud of him so blessed so proud yeah
he peed on the floor this morning but
obviously like he's not feeling well
he's hung over from his birthday he's
hung over if i'm partying and
i just want everyone to keep bruno like
and his birthday and your thoughts you
know yeah i'm gonna put you on blast a
little bit because you didn't like
forget you know on sunday to tell the
podcast about monday like literally you
came into my room at 11. usually in the
morning like we are doing the dates in
the podcast all day like oh oh my god no
this is good for engagement because then
everyone's like toast is up twisted down
because like we're getting twisted it's
my microphone oh my gosh i like i spent
all this time at best buy and she can't
even twist it i spent all this time
building the studio and i'm going to do
it how i like it jenny please like it's
really bothering me like and we don't
have our sign yet so we really need our
logo like presents i'm apparently
engaged martin's telling you keep going
one more thank you for engagement thank
you what you were saying um usually
we're always like doing the date august
15th in the morning on the podcast in
the youtube whatever and
uh and even when i'm downloading the
files like and so i'm very aware of what
the date is but because we did it the
night before i wasn't and i would have
realized yesterday morning if it was a
normal day that it was bryce's birthday
but instead i didn't realize till the
evening jeffy came to my room and i kept
forgetting to tell you and i finally
came out it was bruno's birthday today
and so yeah no we took a backseat
because there's so much going on between
the move and jeffy's brother bruno is
literally molly bernwald
and her whole family forgets her
birthday okay candles but we remembered
and bryce is so beloved he got to sleep
with his mommy last night
his best
there's a lot going on i don't feel bad
for bryce honestly this man lives like a
king i like theo's dinner i don't feel
bad for him
he's so hungry and you know what i
really related to him on that level yeah
and he'll do what it takes to get what
he needs and you know what we love a man
with a plan he's bourdini because he
just finds a way and makes it disappear
and yep exactly like brugini and he's
bryce ringwald
oh bryce
um so i feel like you can dive in i
don't really have a lot to oh i finished
jeanette mccurdy's book
let me tell you how good it was like it
wasn't at maclernia jeanette mclardia it
was so
good
really it got like even more graphic and
more heavy and by the end like you're
going on this journey with her it's like
and the title of the book is really
called like i am glad my mom died
because i don't think she really
realized that she was a victim of abuse
until after her mom died and she was
able to get treatment for eating
disorder which then like obviously you
died into your childhood and her
therapist was like that's like
everything she was describing was like
abuse
um and it's not like the reason why i
found it so difficult is because
it's not like i'm immune to abuse like
you know like you read about it you see
it in tv um but the kind of abuse she
was describing was so different and so
manipulative and like so bizarre like
jeanette mccurdy never
took a shower like herself like showered
herself until she was 16. her mom gave
her a shower every night it was like it
wasn't like sexual it was just so
invasive it was like this way of
controlling jeanette like you can't do
anything without me and if she were to
ask like the one time she had asked like
can i shower myself like i know how to
do it it's like this rage from her mom
it was just really like it was it never
it was abuse you couldn't even like
think of you know what i mean like
typical abuse like verbal physical
emotional it was just
so like
evil
really
that's awful but honestly that's also
like what good writing
does yeah it makes you feel
like the person comfortable she was an
excellent writer it was graphic about a
lot of the stuff like the abuse her
bulimia she was really graphic about
that like
it got to a point where it was so bad
where literally she's on a 16 hour
flight to australia and like every hour
she just like eats and throws up eats
and throws up and she goes to throw up
and she sees one of her molars in the in
the toilet like she'd been throwing up
so much that the acidity from the vomit
was wearing at her teeth and they were
decaying and she literally lost a big
ass tooth in the airplane toilet oh my
god and like she was so like spiraling
then that wasn't even enough to be like
to wake her up she was like oh i'll have
to figure out a way around it
um she's extremely smart and like
extremely strong and the book really
made miranda cosgrove look
really good not that i don't think she's
a bad person but i feel like we don't
know a lot about her and she's not been
one of those nickelodeon kids who's been
vocal about anything that went on during
that time so we don't really know what
her disposition is um she was such a
good friend to jeanette like
so good
um she
really wanted jeanette on the reboot and
she got paramount to agree to paige and
at the same amount that she was getting
even though it's the icarly show she's
carly jeannette still didn't want to do
it but she was like grateful that like
miranda went to bat for her um why
didn't she want to do it
she said like she her mental health
comes first and i think she she like
never wanted to act ever
and so the only thing she's grateful for
from that experience is like the
financial stability it gave her she
never wanted to actually never want to
be famous she hated being famous she
wanted to be a writer her mom would
never let her be a writer and her mom
had like these this childhood trauma
because her mom wanted to be a child
actor
never made it and so i pushed all that
on jeanette so
when the time came for when our carly
was done she did a couple projects and
like none of them were like popping off
and she was like i don't even want to do
this
so she stopped acting
and
then the icarly reboot and she was in a
much better place like she finally got
treatment
after she stopped acting so she's just
gonna go back there what's next for
jeannette well you see her book sold out
on amazon like they're out of copies
yeah so she's like on her instagram
being like you can get the ebook in the
audiobook like we're trying to print
more books i've literally never heard of
that happening no especially simon
schuster like it's a big publishing
house they printed a lot of books right
so that's crazy i think well this is
really kind of like a beautiful ending
because if you read the book you know
like she really just wants to be a
writer and she's such a good writer like
she's extremely
there wasn't a co-writer on the cover
right it's possible she goes writer but
i don't think so it was so personal like
and it wasn't this like really
sophisticated like dense writing it was
just like writing in the mind frame of
whatever age she was at the time
and
i think this is like
she must be thrilled obviously because
everyone's
loving her story but also because all
she's really ever wanted to be is that
she's now a successful writer like a
really successful one obviously she'll
be a new york times bestseller um it's
it's just really good great i'm glad
that you read it me too i still would
love to read it i just
i'm reading very slowly i'm like only 15
into my book take your time
yeah it keeps like people are saying
this book is so good apparently it's
like based on a crazy true story like
crazy i don't know what the crazy thing
is that happened but
something crazy um
so i'm looking forward to enjoying it
but right now she like they keep saying
the same thing over and over again which
is like really annoying no that's tough
like i got it the first time the second
time then third you recommended a book
that i started last night and honestly i
never felt dumber in my life i have no
idea what's going on it was such a good
book of civility by amar tolls like i'm
like
are you guys still at this art gallery
opening like i literally no idea what's
going on oh there are so many in and out
and i'm like where's the gallery like
i'm so confused it's really good it's
new york city 1930s i think it was a
dana recommendation for me and i loved
it so much
we talk about it all the time on the
redheads it's a really great fantastic
book and like well written i just think
like it's important to know thyself and
i'm just like not that smart like
actually okay word smart i'm very tech
smart i mean
oh like street smart right but like
literature-wise like i'm really i don't
bring to like neither am i though okay
i'm really not i tried like when the
first word of the book was like thus
about but that would turn out to be a
quote about matthew 22 right lucas 12 18
yeah but still i was like i felt very
out of my depth yeah okay well
don't worry about it
i'm gonna keep on i send you some more
book wrecks too yeah i know i hope to
read a lot this weekend
and i hope that that inspires me to find
the time to read a lot too even without
going on being number one auntie is my
number one priority always yeah you'll
see it's hard to find the time to read i
know like roldini is a lot of work plus
when we're when like he
we do have a minute
we're working with him like we're doing
this we've got meet and greet we've got
a lot going on no totally but we make
time for old
it's all we make time for it
um no i think it's time no now i think
it's time to jump right in head first to
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode this brings me real
like honor and pride to say is brought
to you by mcdonald's here at the morning
toast it is no secret that we're
obsessed with mcdonald's after a long
day of being the number one auntie
recording the number one podcast is
there anything better than a mcdonald's
fountain diet coke a big french fry and
their iconic chicken sandwich the answer
is no i know you already knew that i
just spoiler alert here's the important
question what's the best mcdonald's
crispy chicken sandwich is it the
standard the spicy the deluxe the right
answer is every single one of them
because as we always say here at the
morning toast the mcdonald's chicken
sandwich is more personal than comedy so
for me like i'm a boring girly you guys
know if you watch my patreon video like
you always are like coming at me for my
bland taste like i'm going standard with
nothing on it except ketchup but some
people are doing extra pickles some
people are doing no tomato like whatever
it is that you want you get at
mcdonald's
it is heavenly whether it's the crinkle
cut pinkle pickle the spicy pepper sauce
however you do it is the right way to do
it
mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich you
can order a head on the mcdonald's app
and try the sandwich that invented the
crispy juicy tender today at
participating mcdonald's the app
download and registration is required
and just do yourself a favor like get
yourself a crispy chicken sandwich from
mcdonald's you literally will not regret
it there's no downside yeah today's
episode is also brought to you by beauty
counter a leader in the clean beauty
industry with the collected mission to
get safer products into the hands of
everyone they believe that dewey that
beauty skin oh my god i cannot talk
today she's just so excited they believe
that beauty should be good for you this
is why they've created a variety of
clean skincare and beauty products such
as the dew skin tinted moisturizer a
daily makeup meets skincare tinted
moisturizer with an spf 20 now that
you're living like sunny i know you're
always supposed to wear spf but like
when it's hot obviously that comes to
mind yes um and having spf in your
makeup products is so important so
important every single day i'm doing it
yeah um so the chicken moisturizer adds
like a really nice coverage for like a
base but also it has spf it's skincare
it's taking care of your skin you're not
gonna break out um it has really good um
other products that go with it like the
all bright vitamin c serum triple acid
aha toner and the all bright facial oil
i like using a facial oil to massage my
face in the morning de-puff
chisel out my jawline
they also have a clean mascara that is
super super popular it gives an ultimate
lift length and volume
um and you just have to check out
beautycounter like if you're looking for
clean beauty products that are good for
you good for the planet and just going
to make you look sickeningly stunning
it's a no-brainer right now they're
offering 30 off your first order in case
you needed another reason to check out
beauty counter and switch to a clean
routine use code toast to save 30 off
your first order from beauty counter
that's code toast to save 30 off your
first order
great thanks so much oh wait let's talk
about it like if you're watching on
youtube you might be honestly shocked
and you need to pick your jaw up off the
floor because you saw me
unveil a new ipad it's what four years
in the making
five years
it's the end of the era beginning of a
new one because i complain you guys
watch me with all my technical errors
over the past few years and i finally
got a new ipad and a new case so that
it's more like a computer that way when
i need to quickly google something it's
very quick and seamless you know me i'm
so changeable like even with the studio
like i have a lot of anxiety there is no
change of versus anxiety here the ipad
had to go the ipad had to go it was
slowing us down oh of course we need to
keep it as a you know momentum don't use
it for other stuff yeah but
it couldn't handle the fast five it was
too slow no the way like it would
literally die after every show after
using it for 45 minutes like calm down
calm down who are you me it was slowing
down the fast side we couldn't allow it
it was because i was like i have this
new glorious ipad i got it in a
different color i didn't get the same
pink i just wanted to do something
different i got purple it's gorgeous
with this white case and it's a new era
it it really is by the way on all fronts
and i love a new ear especially when
it's like going so great right right now
new heroes can be good when they're gone
they can be deeply sad 100 it could give
great depression you know yes that was a
new era yikes
big yikes thanks so let's get into the
stories because our first story is
actually a new era it's called the
glorious age of adele adele is on the
cover of elle magazine doing her thing i
hope they spelled it a dell
a-g-e-l-l-e
why
because she's uncovered oh cute no they
didn't they need you
marketing jeans ron draper's sitting
right next to me
who knew they should have literally had
that you know how like they had the
e-l-l-e on the top
yeah
i'm
literally a graphic designer literally
give her all the ad week awards yeah can
lion's heart come
okay well adele's on the cover of l and
she's talking about the past year and
again she's talking about this and i
read the article and what's so crazy is
this is probably this vegas thing is
like one of the lowest points in her
career no it's like her
what's the word like um
i don't know like
her you know
yeah
what's like the word when it's like the
bad thing you know like i don't know but
it's like
or cancellation it's it's like you're
saying
it's like taylor swift yes reputation
reputation like it's her lowest point
which is just so weird because it's like
i know we think it's a big deal not even
me i don't even think it's a big deal i
just think it's a weird deal i think
it's so suspicious but i think she's
also making it such a bigger change
and she also like has new music video
for 30 that she stole because of the
uh the vegas thing and the less she does
the more we're just thinking about what
we're thinking about this is handled
poorly it's really handled so poorly and
she said like she um didn't want to just
like move on for me to put out her next
music video continue on with the music
she didn't want her fans to think that
she doesn't care but it's like
yeah you know what the way that this was
handled was not great but people cancel
shows all the time yeah it's
no like we get it you care let's move on
no we know but let us move on to
something else by the way i had to
cancel my new haven show so you guys
already got emails what's the t refund
there's no t but like
literally everyone's calling me adele
i'm
i'm the new adult should i go to hiding
and like stop releasing all my new music
yeah wait what is the t no there's no t
like we just have to cancel the shadow
no like there's no there's literally no
taylor we just have to cancel the show
i swear
oh my god i'm literally i've changed my
mind justice for a doll do you think
that it was because like you couldn't it
couldn't be the show that you wanted it
to be no we just had to cancel it like
there was a lot going on like the
schedule like it was just a lot i swear
okay i swear no i believe there's no
change none whatsoever
but i'm being framed and i'm
kind of like feeling it
well so adele went on to explain more of
why just like we said how you know it's
her singing her songs like why does she
need all this
i think it was actually the opposite
where
it was becoming like this big dumb thing
she was so far away from the band it
didn't feel intimate she wasn't like
intimate with the fans and that was not
the show she wanted to i think it was
becoming like a vegas spectacle maybe
the thing is like we really don't care
like straight i was a year ago no that
was a year ago like i actually don't
care anymore like i know and i can't
stop talking about it no i also feel
like this is now the fourth time where
it's like adele sitting down telling
everything like this like the fourth
interview where whether did she sit down
with oprah
that before before
there's just been like a couple like sit
down interviews maybe zayn love we get
it you told us this all already like
please move on yeah this is the worst
thing in your life right and this is
like the
worst thing in her career was like
having to cancel a show it was her
decision too like
i we just thought it was smelly like not
not reputation worthy no like she's
waking up every day thinking about this
and like
no one else is no but like the thing is
we still are and we can't like you know
we're annoying trolls like we are but
also because she doesn't give us
anything new to think about no she keeps
doing the same interview over and over
so it's like you're not gonna keep if
you're not gonna give us new information
like move the [ __ ] off but like shawn
mendes just canceled his tour
i was fine yeah
even though like i did get some details
you know the people in boston who were
like mad at him because he cancelled a
sunday show on a friday
okay but like i'm not going to think
about it every time i think about shawn
mendes no because he doesn't talk about
it like he will move on yeah she came
towards all the time justin bieber just
canceled
his whole torah i had tickets yeah well
that was because of his video yeah and
shawn mendes was because of his mental
health and adele should have just said
it was their mental health and then
people would leave leave her alone yeah
no she has to stop like
you're giving us nothing and you just
keep bringing up the same thing so
stop
yeah it's enough like we're good
we're
there was also a little coke and blame
in there was there yeah so that's so
classic that i really too yeah she's
before she posted the video camera
journey as you want to cancel my new joe
my coven
yeah i hate to see it
she said her team was already ravaged by
absences from the omnicron surge and uh
that was part of it
well that makes sense so
good let's move on yeah let's oh i think
we should all please put out that music
video so that we have something else to
talk about yeah
it's crazy i really did not dive into 30
like at all
i think i listened to it in full maybe
twice it was the best selling album in
the u.s of the year though which doesn't
surprise me because it's still better
than most of the stuff that comes out
right it wasn't uh it wasn't i think her
best work agreed
but that's fine not everything can be
like the best thing ever that you do no
because then there's actually not one
best if everything's the best that's
true that's very true i'm having a
difficult time with this new setup i'm
gonna have to
figure out how to do my new little
laptop you're gonna use theo as your
desk
yes
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah florence pugh confirms that sheen
zach brath broke up earlier this year oh
my god florence because he's doing a
german drama girl like yeah i'm living
for it they quietly broke up in early
2022 after nearly three years of dating
quote we've been trying to do the
separation without the world knowing
because it's been a relationship that
everybody has an opinion on it's all
it's all been good opinions though
really except i guess for the age
difference she told harper's bizarre she
said we just felt something like this
would really give us the benefit of not
having millions of people telling us how
happy they are that we're not together
so we've done that i automatically get a
lumpy throat when i talk about it that's
actually really smart because now by the
time that she won she's sharing on her
own terms and two by the time all the
criticism or whatever feedback comes in
like she is more moved on yeah less raw
that's good for her like own mental
space i feel like so many people shipped
them yes and uh what is the age
difference
so she's 26
and he is
hold on
give me a second gotta google quickly
the student ipad is not turning out to
be everything you thought it was it's
just because theo's on my lap today he's
47.
okay i will say that's a really big age
difference but it's not one that makes
me like nauseous not at all she's 20
she's 26 she's orange she's old enough
to make her own decisions i think where
it gets murky is when you're like
oh have you have you heard 17
29 that's definitely not how the song
goes demi lovato
yeah she's a new song called 17 or 29 i
forget which number it is and she's like
going in
on wilmer valderrama i also thought
people on tick tock like being really
upset with her like saying that the song
is not an accurate retelling of
their relationship like that demi really
sought him out when she was 17 and he
made it a point to be like no you're 17.
they did start dating when she was 18
which is legal but not much better when
he was i guess 18 and 30. um but some of
her fans are like not happy with like
her version of events in the song
and are they her fans
yeah
well where do they know that she sought
him out like her documentary she spoke
about what i was thinking because that's
how i remembered the story and i heard
it somewhere she's spoken about the
relationship publicly many many times
since they've broken up in a positive
way
so i think people are just now confused
but maybe she's just like molded over
and thought about it i don't know but
people are just like
you're contradicting yourself
yeah
but i think but she has admitted that
she was very much the aggressor
in pursuing him um but it's possible
that like that's just kind of how she's
rationalized it afterwards you know yeah
i don't know but so i don't like get
into the demi
like fandom that much but it ended up on
like a weird side of tick tock that's
interesting that reminds me of the book
we read for the redheads my dark vanessa
which is a book that reminds me of the
all too well music video and it's like
this girl who's she might be like 15 and
she has an affair with her teacher and
she thinks that like they're in love
it's not like he you know she didn't
want to be in a relationship but like
you're far too like no and it's up to
him to know it's disgusting that's like
honestly it was probably it was probably
the best book we ever read for the
redheads and it was like the most
affected i've ever been by a book that's
was that joe kate mara i think it's
called the teacher
that was a really graphic show but like
the whole time like this kid is like so
in love with his teacher and then like
if the whole thing blows up she goes to
jail and like years later they meet up
and he's like look at what you did like
you ruined my life
he said that or he did he the teacher
the teacher was a woman yes yes yes so
there's certainly a different stigma
when the teacher is a woman by the way
like the way people talk about it is so
different
okay
it's the same [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah um
and so like the whole time he's like and
she's like this young hot teacher so the
whole time you're like oh he this is
what he wants but it's like not at all
then you see how it affects his life
years later and he they come to meet and
he was like you're literally disgusting
like you're disgusting yeah so
i do think that your opinion on things
can change over time and so i do think
that's probably what happened with demi
yeah but people were like she's like
changing to be controversial and i just
don't think like
i don't think that's fair
i have to one hear the song rewatch
documentary but still like when in
relationships especially with older
people like 17 18 like that's kids it's
working no it's kids yeah now like i
would say one your brain's not fully
forming until you're 25 so if you're
going to be with a 40 year old like i
would say 25 is would be my the cutoff
for me yeah um
and then between 21 and 25 like it it's
there's different levels of maturity
when it comes to relationships i
completely agree
so florence and
zach graf i i thought everyone they
thought they were cute and i think the
age difference is fine there's nothing
immoral about it's just like a little
weird you know yeah especially in
certain photos like she looks really
young and he looks really old like this
one that i'm looking at right here
she looks like she's hanging out with
her dad yeah and yesterday with dad yeah
um well wishes are both the best i do
feel like florence florenceview
um florence p was still very much like
on the rise in her acting career and a
new hot relationship could be just the
thing you know yeah but this was a hot
relationship
and it fizzled and there's
a list
yeah she's on the cover of harper's
bazaar this month probably also
promoting that movie don't worry darling
that she's in
but it just makes me sad because when i
think of their relationship like i think
everybody was obsessed with that yeah
and then now she's talking about and
she's like i didn't want to give the
haters you know this fodder and it's
like what about all the people that
loved you guys like yeah there were so
many people who were like you're he's
too old for you yeah i never saw any
hate it is sad though when people
make decisions in their real life based
on the internet you know yeah especially
when that doesn't feel like that i mean
she knows her mentions better than i do
but just for my purge it doesn't feel
like that was the overwhelming sentiment
yeah i don't think it was but it's easy
to listen to only that i feel like chloe
is someone who
you know has to
who lets that stop affection because she
gets so it's overwhelming no and the
overwhelming narrative is that it's a
negative relationship right but i
i felt like the overwhelming irony here
is that it's positive yeah but they were
so cute
yeah coming to russia next
not harry styles i could add her to the
list yeah that's what i said you also
said kim and pete to the list which is
so sad human shaq
no he's with chloe
okay oh my god kim on the list
kim pete and florence oh and i guess
that graph too even though like i don't
really know him no i don't know who to
set him up with i mean
so for florence and chris evans
that's cute that's cute kim and trevor
noah pete and lori harvey
love it that's curious and that's
age-appropriate she's 25 he's 28. what
came in josh groban
perfection perfection like making a
double date with chloe and chuck no like
you know how kanye used to like for
valentine's day and stuff have like a
piano player like an orchestra like josh
gordon would just like wake up and sing
to him in like four different languages
every day would be valentine's day i
still like love that josh grove and cat
danny who's relationship even though cat
jennings has followed me on instagram a
couple years ago and i'm still like
upset about it um i still think that was
like a really cute
relationship i agree and i feel like he
hasn't dated publicly since then no and
i miss josh gorban and katy perry too
wait could you think of anything better
what yeah that's psychotic
josh groban katy perry has the best
taste in men uh
i'm not into russell brand but john
mayer is what i was trying to say
yeah they were rumored to be dating
which is enough for me personally like
i'm still living in the katy perry john
mayer dating era
like when they came out the song
together they went to the grammys
together and she was wearing that green
seafoam dress and he was wearing that
navy blue suit i feel like i talked
about this maybe once a year um like
that's for me i don't think life will
ever be as good as it was that
week i don't think life will ever be as
good as what i'm about to tell you what
katy perry song the one that got away is
about josh gervais no yeah and he said
he responded on watch what happened to a
comment about it i [ __ ] by the way
and that's why watch live like is
such a good show like every time we're
googling weird things people are always
answering them on watching happens live
he said that he was flattered that the
song was about him but he was also
surprised that it was about him because
the lyrics didn't quite add up
oh and he did confirm on the show that
they were romantically involved in the
past but that they're still good friends
but so it's possible
it's possible though that the song is
not about him
if he feels like it doesn't even ring
true well i mean sometimes you take
artistic liberties maybe the other
songwriter in the room was writing about
their one that got away it was kind of a
fusion maybe i do love when people who
who've dated publicly acknowledged that
songs are written about them in a
positive way like when harry styles was
asked like what he thinks about style
and like the songs that taylor's written
he was like well if anyone's gonna write
a song about you like i'm so lucky it's
taylor swift she's very talented like
it's nice when they say positive things
about it and that sounds like josh
groban i don't i couldn't see josh
groban being like a vindictive
experience um so it's nice to know like
he's appreciative for the art yeah we've
got to get jake gyllenhaal and watch him
have inside well maggie was on and of
course
andy asked her about the scarf like andy
because andy i don't think really knows
like all these crazy conspiracies about
celebrities and like these theories so
they just get questions and they're like
oh this is funny and they ask it they
don't know like maggie gyllenhaal's
probably been dodging that question
since the day she was born like yeah and
when when andy asked her like he didn't
know it was like a loaded question he
was just like what's this funny thing i
saw on twitter you know yeah and that's
why we love it yep it's true and she was
like
what is that like everyone's always
saying it to me i'm like i have no idea
sure jack sure she goes home she smells
the scar scarf
retires her underneath literally
okay are you ready for our next story
which story is it it's the third story
yeah i think i'm ready for the next
third story that's brought to you by
betterhelp
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to
how will you take care of your car how
well you take care of all the things in
your life that you have like you have a
million cars you know in your life you
don't have the same car forever you're
gonna have the same grain forever you're
gonna be seeing body forever you should
be taking care of it always and better
help is a great place to start i never
thought of it
this is our fourth studio like yeah took
as good care as my mental health as i
did the studio
sweeping all the time i've just gotten
two major things out of today's episode
so there's many ways to support a
healthy brain
yeah
that and one that got away there are
plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain
and there's better help online therapy
so you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours it is much more
affordable than in-person therapy what i
really like about better help is when i
started um it's very common to like hop
around to different therapists and
better help makes it really easy and
like not awkward like you're not vibing
with someone like not everyone's gonna
vibe all the time so they make it really
easy to switch it up till you get
comfortable they have tons of different
options so whether that's video chatting
texting chatting or
calling on the phone like they have a
ton of different options and our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast
great thank you yeah welcome our next
story asap rocky is hit with assault and
weapons charges over 2021 shooting
rapper asap rocky was slapped with
assault on weapons charges monday in
connection with the november altercation
with a former friend in la the manhattan
native was slapped with two counts of
assault with a semi-automatic firearm
with allegations of personally using a
firearm according to prosecutors he
allegedly pointed a gun at one time asap
mob rap collected member asap rally and
later fired twice in his direction
quote discharging a gun in a public
place is a serious offense that could
have ended with tragic consequences not
only for the person targeted but also
for innocent bystanders visiting
hollywood no it's so true you can't just
like point it on a judah even if you're
not like gonna kill someone you never
know where that bull's gonna go of
course they are there are so many people
who die by stray bullets you know it's
like what are you doing it's so dumb um
and i felt like this story i thought
about this the other day like remember
when we were on the toast it was like
breaking news uh he was
arrested at lax and then we like never
heard it was like kind of like how the
fbi
uh seized jake
paul's house and like whatever happened
to that you know that is a great mystery
of the world we absolutely must know i
know so i felt like this story was
falling into that category but obviously
this is now an update um this is so dumb
and irresponsible like what are you
doing like just being so flimsy with
guns like
dumb um
but not like to totally like change
subjects like do you ever find out what
rihanna's baby's name is
no
i'm and now i'm so used to not knowing
kylie kylie oh my god i don't even say
like i'm just like fine with it i don't
know you know it's like at one point
remember the day she announced wolf i
said on the tuesday i was like i'm dying
to know like please i guess because i
hadn't named i hadn't you had it yet and
i was like very invested in baby naming
but also like when someone doesn't tell
you something like for so long
eventually we stopped caring so i think
that's part of what it is too like we
she's not telling us like let's move on
you know i will be shocked if she
doesn't tell us the season of
kardashians for sure uh but then i'll
move on it's also coming back so soon i
know september 22nd yes also did you see
the rumor i don't know where i saw this
that kim and pete broke up because he
proposed and and i told you that oh we
did it and then i saw them writing but i
don't know who wrote it and
that basically like you know he just
gets too caught up like kind of exactly
what he did with ari he like proposed
too soon it was too much for kim but i
don't know why you have to break up with
someone when they propose to you and
you're not ready you're literally acting
like me we have this conversation right
no i know but i i just now in the movie
and now i'm believing that that's what
happened when you are i didn't think
that was what would happen got it now
i've heard it twice
but and also i wouldn't understand why
if kim had to break up with him because
he proposed and he was like just too in
love with her she would still be in love
with him so like how could she be so
like
okay with breaking up she's on kylie's
birthday you know she's probably like
partying through tears yeah but she
seems fine i think she seems fine too i
think if
if the proposal story is the truth like
maybe she really just like was treating
us like a rebound kind of like get back
out there thing and like
to have continued a relationship with
him when he's so serious and like she's
so not that's why he's seen someone's
time and that's weird especially like
someone who's in there who's 28 like
those are important years like i think
like as an older woman she's probably
like mature enough to realize that yeah
that's if that's what happened but
it just doesn't jive with everything she
said on ellen about like she's a serious
girl she's a relationship girl that's
true and he got a brand like she knew
when he got a brand this is forever that
is true it's that ellen interview threw
me through a loop and she's everything
for me that's true that's true
oh no
um but that tastes like rocky yeah um
that's bad stuff yeah if that's what
happened you know
are you ready for our next story yum
circling back to jlo and ben's wedding
they are having a lavish celebration
this weekend at their georgia estate
it's their vote that there's a state who
knew just one month after their
allotment what have happened to courtney
and travis's big la wedding well i mean
they have the biggest wedding ever no i
know but like there was like 25 people
there i know but they said they were
gonna do like a big party maybe after
his tour maybe i'm loving watching her
on tour i
literally didn't even know that well do
you follow her on instagram like yeah
but i don't think i interact with her a
lot so i don't think her stories come up
to like the front of my feet got it well
she's just being like a literal tour
white look at that so they're just in
all these cities that's cute and machine
gun kelly is the opener
and he zip line across the city i saw
that i didn't realize that travis was on
that tour yeah i thought it was because
mgk was on tour with our laveen they
were co-headlining the tour cute but
maybe that's over
perhaps okay and now travis is on tour
courtney's with him and she's just like
posting from all these places in this
country that's so cute you know not
cleveland cleveland she's showing like
the cleveland skyline oh my god she's
such a cleveland girl aren't we all with
the kardashians it like always comes
back to blue blood for the country
for america for us yeah always come back
to sleep true today one day
so far it's okay no no it was just like
saying the phrase not the phrase yeah
yeah yeah here's the last cleveland days
and the cleveland's have the cavaliers
so true so do we though
so do we anyways jayla and ben will
continue celebrating their club with a
three-day wedding news chat again so you
didn't think shitload was just gonna do
it small
following their impromptu july vegas
nuptials they're set to have their dream
wedding celebration at ben's rice
borough state in georgia this weekend an
insider says it ben's or is it theirs
that's conflicting headline and text
it's going to be all about jlo ben wants
all of the focus to be on her on their
big day
i just sometimes
remember
that these two like literally got
married
i'm getting like fatigue
i'm no i'm having the opposite
experience where like once it feels
fresh to me and i'm like i can't believe
that this is what happened then it all
started with madison lacroix well that's
the thing
that is obviously the thing to take away
from from this story um do you think
she'll be invited she should be she's
the reason for the season i wonder if
there was like ever any communication
between jlo never madison no never
never never
um i'm happy for them like i'm
definitely getting like over them
quickly they've been they're like
they're just like maybe
i feel like a lot of my fatigue has to
do with ben affleck like i feel like
he's been like kind of like a tabloid
like mess for like 10 years
and like i love jlo like
i'm on the j train you know yep but when
it comes to news about these two i'm
just like everything gives like planted
vibes you know like they're so pretty
yeah she can't help herself yeah because
she's just like a machine yeah and mogul
it just you know
it is what it is i'm just glad that it's
not coming from the newsletter yeah yeah
that's true i was definitely having
newsletter fatigue
yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story oh my god leo what's the final
story
the final story
[Music]
[Music]
and i know you didn't like wearing the
cone
that's an itchy foot i brought theo's
cone with him but yesterday he was so
good so it was his first day not wearing
the cone which is so i don't want him to
wear the cone but every time i turn
around he's licking his foot and the
doctor said like his foot is healing so
the licking is not so bad but i just
wanted to heal like yeah but now that
i've experienced theo in my home i know
exactly how like he definitely got his
infection here because the minute you
open the door to let him outside he
starts walking and he doesn't stop he
has a wanderlust he really does he
doesn't respond to his name like he
tunes everyone out it's just him and the
great outdoors he has a bumper sticker
on his crate that says not all who
wander are lost not like other dogs yeah
he's um actually that's exactly like
other dogs yeah he's an explorer he's
very inspired by emilio vespucci
and um amerigo
what's the one who's named america's
named after america with speech is
yeah
so why isn't the united states of
america
that's so true like why did they like
they literally colonized on his name
like they took the
the truck show
americo is his name okay so they made it
feminine yeah actually
which i love that for us me too but it
doesn't really track with like back in
the day like 1776 like women didn't even
have rights they couldn't even leave
their house but now like the country
they all fought for that they're all
like obsessed with they're going to make
feminine
something's a mess maybe we did have
rights and like no good like maybe there
was just like a respect for women for
you
i would love to hear
someone i'm sure ben franklin wrote
about it somewhere why you know what
google why is america why is america a
woman
right because i just think like
it doesn't really track with everything
i know about women's rights up until
this point
or when did they decide to make america
a woman was it in 1776
um
yeah woman as a symbol of america
and everything is like um
the hill america is not a she oh my god
okay like we're looking for
we no it's like lady liberty right right
and when
and when i feel like that song like um
oh beautiful it's not oh ham so no but
also i feel like in those classic songs
they say her yeah okay
[Music]
we would never know i just feel like you
should be able to sing like national
past times and not be penalized that's
how i feel about happy birthday but it's
literally the most copyrighted song like
on the planet so sick yeah sick thank
you wonder are they male or female oh
then they're giving me gender statistics
anyway something to chew on and sound
off in the comments why america is a
woman and what does that say about our
founding fathers and is it called
america to make america
feminine yeah because america is a woman
hmm
that's three interesting things you
learned here today no for sure i'm so
glad i brought a camera yoga spoochie so
that you brought up emilio with history
wait maybe i am smart
literally food for thought very
interesting what was the story we were
talking about i haven't gotten to oh
fifth and final story kristen chenoweth
shocked steve harvey with her racy
celebrity family feud answer
so kristin chenoweth is on celebrity
family feud and the prompt was after the
lips what is your favorite part of a man
to kiss
though her answer can't be heard in the
clip what she said was clearly enough to
make everyone in the studio including
the host pause and laugh for a few
moments on the family feud youtube
channel they noted that the answer
rhymed with heinous
so kristen chenoweth answered penis
for after the lips what is your favorite
part of romantic is and it was not on
the board okay but like what's the right
answer like a neck
i guess a hand like it's really like
obviously everyone's mind is going to go
like genitalia
of course that's where everyone's
finding something oh she
kristen chenoweth said it
and that's the thing about kristin
chenoweth she's gonna say what we're all
thinking what are the other answers
family feud is low-key like flawed in
the sense that
the top five answers are on the board
and like 100 people surveyed yeah and so
two people had dumb [ __ ] answers and
they get on the board right
eyebrow you know like
that's why i think the game is flawed
it's a fun game
it's a good time steve does a great job
so what do we think the top answers are
lip oh so you it's not lips it's not
like cheeky neck hands hands why would i
kiss a man's hand never mind no but like
you know like no that's just that's the
opposite yeah i guess a woman's hand no
it's like a thing people do like you
pick up someone's hand and you kiss it
like right here okay it's a thing i
guess so that's three
chest
ears
well isn't that also neck like behind
the ear that's your mag head farther
forehead
with kisses people are people every time
we say forehead like they hate the way
we say it and we have so many new
stories
forehead overhead no we say far ahead
yeah and it's wrong
and we know that but
i don't want to be right so true
so those were the past five stories and
maybe you needed to know them you didn't
okay here's the thing let's be honest
you didn't need to know the stories um
but you didn't need to know a lot of the
interesting factoids that came from
today from historians josh groban katy
perry america
physical and mental health needs to be
you're with you your whole life mm-hmm
is that true that's the way you should
feel your whole life what's that from
people that's the way you should feel
your whole life never saw the movie but
it's just in the commercial over and
over in the commercial over and over
again i started only murders um
oh theo you little [ __ ] rascal i knew
you had something in your mouth i
literally just bent down to pick it up
he was hiding it you see it that little
piece of plastic yeah it's from he's
gaslighting me because i'm like oh
there's nothing there
um i started early murders and honestly
like i'm on the first episode and
i think it's like the best show ever
and i thought it was like so bad but
like i'm just not in it you know we're
not in it and you know i mean we could
get into it together but we also have to
read yeah but the reason i brought that
up is carl delevingne is a character in
the show now
she's like this cool like art gallery
owner which is so cara
that actually is pretty car yeah she's
pretty good actress
yeah she loves acting she left the
modeling world to act yeah she's pretty
good
so happy for her nice to see other
people living their dreams totally
that's our show our show ours
remind you about tomorrow six o'clock in
is it in fort lauderdale
that's really great i think it is i'm
pretty sure i looked up this morning um
jackie and i are doing a meet and greet
um all the information is on spritz
instagram page because it is a spritz
meet and greet at a liquor store it's
gonna be so much fun so we can't wait to
see you guys there
anything else oh tickets at
available.com for lauderdale primo primo
liquor sunrise
i'm sorry i'm uncultured it's fine
literally thank you so much for
listening to the morning just on the
monday morning show where we do all the
fast face stories every monday through
friday on youtube watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasting for
podcasting we found something spotted by
action stitcher public radio i haven't
really passed box all the places so for
use and podcast find us morning
challenge class to review about our
beautiful soundings where we are thank
you guys so much for being toasters we
love you with all of our hearts we hope
you guys have an incredible day and
we'll see you tomorrow for
hot day
oh yeah bye